mr president have you instructed
secretary madison and the others working
on this bill with congress
to meet some of the demands that
democrats have made
well i thought we had a deal last night
and then the democrats changed the deal
so
we had a deal last night that was going
to be phenomenal for the workers which
is my
number one my number one aim i want to
take care of the workers
and we had a deal i was pretty sure we
had a deal last night if you would have
told me
at a certain time like about nine
o'clock i would have told you we pretty
much have a deal
and then all of a sudden the change uh
changed fairly rapidly and
you know it was unacceptable would have
been bad for our country
and they were asking for things that
would have not been good i mean things
that
that bore no relationship to what we're
talking about we said that's not the
game we can't play that game
so uh we'll see look the democrats do
want to make a deal
but jeff i thought we had a deal last
night and if you
come further this process weeks or
months from now and decide that
further stimulus is needed will you be
able to work with speaker pelosi on that
i'll work with anybody to help the
american people i will i don't care who
it is i'll work with anybody
if i feel i'm going to help the american
people and the american worker